what's the deal with airplane peanuts
because most realtors are brain dead and
and they they're amassed these large
fortunes
by being brain and it's like it's the
funniest
because none of the interactions are
real like none of the like they're all
like he's like
you want it for eight but it's gonna be
for you know we're too far apart it's
really like nine
but like you know a lot of those real
conversations are like a realtor turning
around and going listen
be like my client's trying to get out of
china with his life right now you know
you know the world bank you know this
guy they want him for genocide he
poisoned a river
but he loves this infinity pool he's
gonna get his money out here
but you gotta listen i mean this guy i
mean he's a they want him for narco
trafficking he's coming
you know this is the sinaloa cartel
let's make a deal
yeah let's go you know you need and
instead it's like i like the windows
it's like that's not it no
that is
all the people that own these houses are
like fertile russian fertilizer magnets
oh yeah chinese amusement park tycoons
yeah yeah oh yeah now i bet you were a
[ __ ] savage uh what did you do
subprime mortgage
i was i sold self-praying mortgages
because i believe in people and their
ability to oh no
that's number one that's number one and
i i would stop from doing that by a
totalitarian government
who does not believe in people the way
that i do so
sorry would you tell people who were
like i don't know if i can afford this
you're
like dude by the way i'm looking at
america is a country of thieves and
criminals yeah
no one said i don't think i can afford i
love true by the way i love that that's
such an innocent great way to think
about it yeah like there's someone on
the phone where i'm like
hey we could get you 300 grand thursday
and then go like this i don't know
if i can afford it no it's america
everyone's a derby they're like i can't
they're like can we get it tuesday
yeah we get it yeah so it's actually
not i mean i'm sure the predatory
landing went on things like that went on
but the majority of people that i worked
with were
uh selfish yeah scoundrels
yeah that wanted money where you ever
gave them money did you
i bought a subprime more i bought a
house with a subprime mortgage you did
yeah did you ever get to the
like did you ever have somebody whatever
who's i don't know the ins and outs of
it but applying
and you looked at their stuff you're
like there's no way we can give this guy
anything well the worst one we had was a
guy who was clearly like had dementia
or didn't know where he was and his son
wanted to open up a strip club in miami
and his son just took all the money out
of his house and we were sitting at the
closing
and we're signing papers this old guy's
like struggling to sign papers and his
son is like
keep signing daddy it's almost over and
the closing attorney said i'm not really
comfortable with this and i'm like yeah
it ain't great
but you know i mean at that point you
know what are you gonna do
yeah yeah shout out to the vasquez um
but there again it's a guy that came to
me he's like my father's you know an old
guy i want to suck all the money out of
his house yeah and go up into a strip
club it's like all right how's that
strip club doing
you know i don't know tom but
if i wasn't betting man yeah you know i
don't know i bet that's a great business
i think
it really does i love sales i miss it
and i
just i love it i love her i love sitting
in a room
with uneducated people calling people
over the phone and trying to build an
empire
i'm here to tell you all that
i think i'm leaving tick tock no
i've enjoyed all the friendships thanks
for turning
i didn't know you were allowed to be
honest if you were over 19.
like i had no idea that they were 60
year olds leaving tick tock oh there are
like emotions making an announcement
you're like emotionally going i have
made a lot of friendships here it's like
that's illegal
that's just against the law what do you
think you've made a lot of prejudices
here
right what are you talking about i mean
we had been day drinking in florida yeah
my family and we saw these little kids
like fifth graders
yeah um by the pool and this place and
uh
we walked in on them and they were
choreographing we're like what are you
doing and we've been drinking
right and they're like oh and they're in
their school uniforms they're like we're
making a tick tock and we both were like
we're on tick tock and and uh they were
like
oh okay these are like 10 11 year old
girls they're gonna get kidnapped and
then they're like what's your
handle and i was like i've spelled it
out for them and then as we walked out i
realized that the last
one i had posted was me pulling my
nipples and going like
that but i was like oh we gotta go we
gotta
we gotta get out of here you know
i mean yeah it's one of those things man
it's like old people have facebook
that's where you go yeah that's where
you go to scream into the void talk
about your new operation
yes talk about donald trump talk about
dead animals
i mean that's what it is that's what
you're there that's what it's for
go back to where it's sunny i love my
mom very much because she bought me
tickets to boston to see my dad
march 7th on saturday at 3 p.m
in the afternoon bye boston
okay i bet there's a bunch of kidnappers
that are like pass
because he just gave them all the
information to kidnap them but a bunch
of kidnappers just looked at each other
and like
yeah you can take that one i'm good
what made you [ __ ] pull this one dude
because he likes to go to boston you're
not happy for him he's going to see his
dad
because you're you you said you lie out
of respect you lie
i bet your online game is tight dude
well it's
lies yeah i'm saying how good are your
dating lines
i make everything up i i make everything
up
give me walk me through most people on
the sites think i'm amy schumer
you know that's my no i mean i just i i
think it's hard to make stuff up now
because people cut you i'm
somewhat public people can kind of look
me up yeah but you know these people
don't know
you know they think i'm doing great i'm
doing really good but like they don't
know
so wait are you on like raya or are you
on i am but that one sucks
why does it i heard it's fun i heard
it's just tommy lee met brittany furlong
on raya maybe for gabe dude i don't know
it's just not that
great it's people it's supposed to be
like the celebrity app but are you
always okay do you go between being like
i want to meet
someone yeah to date or you're always
are you basically
i'm i'm always just like would i just to
meet somebody maybe hang out with it's
cool yeah okay
but you know sometimes if you meet
somebody to date that's cool too but i'm
not
you're not looking for it not at this
moment okay i got you i got you you know
and it's
you're full of lies on there well i'm
i'm embellishments
yeah distortion you know like whatever
like what well
just just the idea of like you know i'll
tell people i've been to countries i
haven't been to
you know what i mean like i'll start
talking about japan i've never been to
japan
like i'll talk i'll be i'll be like the
best sushi no offense is in japan
and the guy's like what do you mean i'm
like no offense but i date like younger
guys
in their 20s or whatever and they're
like they don't know anything and
so i'm like oh yeah oh that sushi's good
but it's probably better in osaka
and i was in osaka yeah but like he's
like no offense
yeah i tell them no offense because i'm
like you're probably not living that
kind of life
that's okay but the best sushis in japan
and you know things like that they're
like i would love to travel with you
yeah i make up
geography like i just make up things
that i you know i love it i respect it
so yeah
yeah i mean you know nothing crazy yeah
yeah but i mean you should
i i gotta you gotta lie yeah a little
bit
yeah for sure i mean the the country is
run by liars
the most successful people in america
are liars yeah um
everyone you see on a billboard is
probably a liar i don't know what to
tell you
it'll be fun as soon as you get that
laugh and you're in you're like oh i'm
back in
and it's amazing um but then staying
they're closing all the parking garages
in new york now
at midnight because homeless people i
guess are just walking down into them
and they're like
hey this is a fun cave yeah yeah what
could happen here
yeah i like cars
yeah yeah
you know like i imagine like homeless
people like there's a
there's a a cave full of luxury cars
two blocks away yeah we don't have to be
in the rain tonight right
and so they are closing those
at midnight so that me and my my opener
we get back and we're driving around the
city trying to find a spot
everything's just weird man we went into
a bodega at like one
we're like standing there there's a
homeless woman in there
begging for tea the dude's like it's
your third tea
and then you're looking at two guys that
are kind of walking around the bodega
and you're like
something feels off like are they about
to whip a gun out am i just paranoid
because of
the news nobody's out at night new york
city used to be and i lived there for
years
bumping dude bombing three a.m i'm i'm
being a diner
yelling at people yeah about how [ __ ]
this business was you know
i have been denied the amount of
bitter resentful bile that came out of
my mouth
as marinara sauce was flying out of it
mozzarella stick by just being like
the denial this [ __ ] that's a special
um just nasty real horror
i wasted so much in your like i loved it
it was amazing
but like uh just the amount of time i
spent walking around being
angry yeah and not in awe of what an
amazing city it was like my opener
he he paints this picture of like it's
so amazing
you